August 2013 an aerial photograph taken
by an Australian government survey team
reveals something unusual in a remote
patch of the outback a huge pattern of
bright red pock marks scarring the
landscape for hundreds of square miles I
get kind of creeped out when I see
images of pustules and stuff and that's
kind of what it looks like right here
just really a bad case of acne or
something the photograph is taken near
the remote town of Newman in the Pilbara
a sparsely populated desert region of
Western Australia so you've got a lot of
green and then all these like very
evenly spaced brown spots they're just
so evenly spaced that's the thing that's
really remarkable so what's really going
on here the Outback makes up around 70
percent of Australia's 2.9 million
square mile and mass but these red pock
marks appear only in the Pilbara region
this image is fascinating it's something
like I've never seen before
Jetson thinks that something much more
mind-boggling is going on he believes
that the plants are organizing
themselves and you see that the plants
are arranging themselves by
self-organization to maximize water
access and to grow better gets in has a
theory that the plants have evolved to
grow in circles as an adaptation to
survive in such a dry desert in arid
environments when water is not enough to
sustain a complete coverage with
vegetation plants create patterns and
these plants are simply forming a circle
in order to maximize access to water the
soil insanity circles actually helps
conduct moisture out to the plants on
the outside as if some higher
intelligence is directing them the
plants arrange themselves to form large
circular catchment areas these act as
rain collectors which then direct any
water back towards the plants
the smart plant theory is still unproven
but it could offer an answer to the
mysterious circle seen in two deserts
more than 6000 miles apart fairy circles
here in the Pilbara just another example
of how you know nature responds to the
to the climate it's got plants are
smarter than you think